here do you need a slide on Peru that's
okay all right on purpose she didn't
offer peppermint as a bully she wants
the crown what's the ground grow heavy
is the head that wears a crown my neck
hurts let's get rid of this mother who
do you want to hand it to I don't know I
don't know let's keep it RuPaul's Drag
Race Season 8 champ Bob the drag queens
reign as America's next drag superstar
comes to an end on June 23rd but first
we got Bob to weigh in but all things
season 9 favorite moment of season 9 oh
my god you get favorite moment of season
9 was hands-down RuPaul versus Valentina
that was a moment it will go down in
history history that is good TV take
that thing off of your mouth I'd like to
keep it on please it's a lip-sync what
part of that do not understand take that
thing off your mouth moment of the
season least favorite moan of the season
maybe the Charlie High's lipstick come
on Charlie do something Charlie it looks
like she's telling children and get off
her lawn
i-i-i wanna go and she did and she
didn't go ask you shall receive people
don't think I can of course I can
lip-sync favorite fashion moment of the
season Shay cool a construction worker
look hands down so good I don't even
think about that
least favorite fashion moment Alexis's
hair in the Native American challenge I
like that you got so specific just just
her hair yeah there there's all type of
the hair that was not a great fashion
moment favorite challenge the roast I
wish there was on my season I love
making fun of people Ross Mathews has
the face of a young gay man and the
voice of an adult woman so the opposite
of Tamar Braxton
[Laughter]
[Applause]
good showing other than the roast a
challenge from this season that you
really would have wanted to do I would
have loved to have done a cheerleading
challenge that sounds dangerous I would
have probably killed myself if I want to
do ratchet drag next week can you give
me any tips if you want to do like
memorable drag NICs we got to give you
some tips would you go back and do in
all-stars are you just like one and done
and I would win end of interview
[Music]
you
[Music]